I saw you've described it before as the
slowest aha moment in history perhaps
but you were coming to this realization
that you were going to have a result
that which you were not expecting how
did you individually deal with it
because the world welcomed it when it
came out but as you were analyzing the
data I'm beginning to see that this
result
were you doubtful were you thinking this
is not this is not what we should be
seeing there's something wrong I just
thought it was wrong but just it was
gonna be wrong for sure as simple or
dumb it isn't like we would say math
there or in these sophisticated analyses
that usually means a bug in a computer
program but that it would be wrong for
that reason and as it evolved I started
thinking maybe at least it's wrong for
an interesting reason something that you
know we won't kick ourselves and say we
should have known that I'm pretty amazed
that it survived to this day at face
value of what we I thought it was right
and I guess there's the other element
which is there's a chain of analysis
that we all have to do and many steps in
the chain you have to calibrate and so
in the very first days of the of the
measurement wave when you first put the
chain together you often put the chain
together and put the point in the plot
just to make sure that you show that the
chain of all holds together then it
works and then you plan to go back and
fix you know and you know tune each of
the different operation steps the wrong
way to make sure that there's you've got
all your eyes dotted and your t's
crossed but that's what we also I think
in the very earliest stages thought that
as we start to put back into all the
calibrations the plots would home in to
sank a little more sensible and of
course as we do those checks it just
told you no more but not sensible I
think I think the flavor of our analysis
was different yes didn't that I think we
had our tool kit and we were going to
take the data through that and see the
answer at the end and when we saw it we
were kind of stuck only with maybe we
have made a mistake in a state we have
city of pre-calibrated everything he had
recalibrate really just want
and you're like oh that's not so let's
go through each step I gave and what
went wrong right so that was me I just
said uh all right where'd we miss nice
look but you should say that and most of
what a scientist does I think is look
for your own mistakes okay that's not
unusual that you're spending a lot of
your time trying to figure out is what
I've done today correct is what I did
last month correct and sometimes it's
this notion that you know you came to
ask the question so what did you set out
to prove I don't think any of us have to
prove anything you know in the in these
things we actually just don't have to
make a measurement and make measurements
right we were trying to prove we're
trying to prove was the universe slowing
down a little or was it slowing down a
lot you had gone through the idea of
testing this I mean we knew we could do
that but I just kind of figured that was
an irrelevant question